well this city has been under um
bombardment for a few days now there's
been some heavy fighting to the east of
mikolai in fact
we're told that russian forces are
probably about 20 kilometers from
this
site where i'm standing now this is one
of the main
hospitals overnight there was some
shelling 53 people were injured
including seven children
and
around half of this city has now
fled
to the west over the bridge over the
river which is about a kilometer long
and heading towards the other key port
city of
odessa and when you when you walk around
here it does feel
quiet
there's obviously lots of military on
the street corners there's lots of
sandbags they're being very protective
of the hospital obviously that's that's
a key site
and one of the other bridges across the
river has this huge iron drawbridge
which is normally used to let ships
through in boats that's been raised now
it's one of the biggest obstacles i've
ever seen on a bridge it's huge and that
will hopefully protect uh the rest of
this city some people are queuing here
for um the pharmacy and the supermarket
obviously trying to get some
provisions in but this city has been
under attack now for days um some of the
buildings have been hit by shelling some
of them being hit by rockets and it's
obviously one of the key targets for the
russian military all of these black sea
ports along the south of this country
are key uh uh
just west of here is odessa they are
preparing themselves we've been there a
few days and if the russians are able to
secure this city mikhail
and odessa then they would effectively
cut ukraine off by the sea and that
would be strategically very important
we've just been to speak to some
officials at the hospital we understand
that the vast majority of the people
from this attack
last night ended up in here and
hopefully we'll go and speak to a few of
them but everybody is very worried here
in mikalai mikhailov
they can hear the shelling in the
distance they know the russian troops
are very near
there's a huge amount of territorial
defense people who have given their time
they've dropped everything to try and
defend their city they're now standing
on street corners behind sandbags and
all the roads in and out are lined with
checkpoint after checkpoint it took us
about two hours to get in to this city
it's so fortified and as i say it's
almost split down the middle by a river
that long bridge which connects it to
the road to odessa if anything happened
to that then the only route out
of this city right now would be to go
through territory which is occupied
by the russian military so this city is
is bracing itself for a potential siege
situation as the russians seem
determined to take some of these key
ports